dear professor beard ladies and
gentlemen
when we are talking about the pandemic
it is usually hard to find good news
but when we look to science this picture
is completely different
if there has been one bright spot in
this crisis
it was the unprecedented level of
scientific collaboration
thousands of dedicated scientists have
worked day and night
to analyze data to advise policy makers
and to develop and test vaccines as well
as medicines
they have saved countless lives
and i thank them more from the bottom of
my heart
but there's one scientist one expert
one colleague who has been for me
the face of this european global and
scientific community
and that person is peter peart
professor piert has been my advisor
since the beginning of the pandemic
i could not have had a wiser and more
helpful virologist
to accompany me through this challenging
month
peter peart embodies the best of science
he is a shining example of the positive
contribution
that a scientist advising politicians
can make
today i want to thank you dear peter
for the quality of your advice and
for your commitment to our european and
global approach
in fighting this pandemic working with
you was always a pleasure
whenever i had an urgent question a
short text message was enough
and i had the answer straight away
and whether we were discussing the
consequences of the alpha and
delta variants or the issues of
intellectual property rights
or other pressing matters you remained
calm and helped to put even the most
serious things
into perspective i quickly realized
that we were in very able hands because
there
is no virus that could really scare
peter
he's a pioneer in the fight against
viruses
back in 1976 he was among those who
detected ebola
and in the 1980s he was at the forefront
of the fight against aids pierce led the
research on hiv
mostly in sub-saharan africa he worked
in burundi and tanzania
in kenya and zaire and was the co-leader
of the first international aids research
program
so in drawing conclusions and
recommendations
from scientific evidence peter peart
brings to benefit
this enormous real-world experience
in addition when it comes to global
health issues
peter peart knows all the relevant
stakeholders
most of them on a personal basis
his network from scientists to
politicians
from the heads of the big pharmaceutical
companies to leading ngo activists
is second to none
this is what makes this advice
especially valuable for policy makers
peter was a professor of microbiology
and of public health
at the institute of tropical medicine
and antwerp
the free university of brussels and the
university of nairobi
and his scientific output is staggering
until now peter has written 17 books
and published more than 600 scientific
articles
he has worked at the united nations the
who and at universities
across the world until the london school
of hygiene and tropical medicine
became his professional home after more
than 10 years
at the helm of this wonderful
institution
he is now stepping down as director
i know that he will be hugely missed
there
but i'm very happy that professor pierre
continues to be my special advisor on
covet 19. and he will continue to lead
the commission's panel of
national science advisors because the
next pandemic
must not find us unprepared
during this crisis we have seen what
europe can achieve
together our european response to the
pandemic has been
united and strong
and dear peter this would not have been
possible without
you i warmly wish you
every success and every happiness
for the future and i look forward to
continuing working with you
thank you so much